una respuesta con carácter excepcional
el gobierno francés se recibirá los 234
migrantes que a bordo de losan biker
buscan una nueva vida la decisión se da
en el contexto de la negativa de la
Administración italiana de acoger a los
rescatados raza situación en este
contexto Francia decidió
excepcionalmente compensar el
comportamiento inaceptable del gobierno
italiano e invitar al barco a venir al
puerto militar de tulón debería llegar
temprano en la mañana de este viernes 11
de noviembre
el tema provocó fricciones entre París y
Roma el ministro de interior francés
Gerard dharmanan informó además que su
país tomará medidas para reforzar los
controles en sus fronteras interiores
con Italia a pesar del permiso otorgado
para el atraque de la embarcación cuatro
migrantes Fueron trasladados por vía
aérea este jueves a un hospital de
córcega por motivos de salud la geñón
en una reunión con varios de mis
homólogos tal como solicitó el
presidente macron las últimas horas
todos estaban conscientes de que debemos
poder llevar las cosas de manera
diferente para que Italia no pueda
beneficiarse al mismo tiempo de la
solidaridad Europea y ser egoísta con
una cara de humanidad difícil de
comprender ya que los refugiados
Especialmente los niños están pidiendo
ayuda en su cuerpo
entre ambas naciones por la migración es
poco común sin embargo este asunto
genera tensiones en 30 integrantes de la
Unión Europea al ser un espacio en gran
parte libre de controles fronterizos